Everything you own from your clothes to
your car to your wife or your husband is
going to forget you and move on and be
replaced the moment you die. That's what
Allah says
you are busy with the worldly affairs
until you visit the grace. Brothers and
sisters Masjid Norway the one that we
built is looking to another Masjid
around the area of Norway where there's
so many Muslims that do not have
somewhere to pray. This Masjid is only
$500,000 and any donation that you give
will go towards your Akhira because when
you enter that grave nobody's going to
remember you except Allah
so make it count brothers and sisters
and donate towards this Masjid inshallah
a new project that's only $500,000 and
believe me if every single one of us
give 1 pound 10 pounds 100 pounds 1000
pounds that's going to be something you
will never regret on your Qiyamah and
everything that you lose is going to
perish and go but your deeds on your
Qiyamah are not.
Donate to the link inshallah. Let's get
to the video. As-salamu alaykum
brothers and sisters and dear friends.
Yes, first time meeting a hoodie looking
like a crow.
Brothers and sisters so today's video is
a footage that's coming out of Tel Aviv
stolen lands of
these oppressors these violent doers may
Allah
deal with them and allow the lands to
return back to its
inheritors which are the Palestinians
who lived with the Christians and Jews
in peace and protected the Jews against
anti-Semitism that came from the
Christians. Here is now brothers and
sisters a video footage couple of video
footages
which I checked some were saying that
this was from Texas it's not but it's
actually even the Daily Mail has written
about it that it is from Tel Aviv. What
are thousands if not millions of crows
doing around Tel Aviv flying around?
There's two things. Number one those who
follow the scripture the Christian
scripture etc. We believe there are some
truths in it that's left after
corruption that this is not a good sign.
And it can't be a good sign cuz we also
going to come what does Islam say about
this? Let's watch the footages for
ourselves inshallah. And number two
there is something more sinister
happening and it can be pointing out to
something more devastating even if not
it is bad omen. Let's watch the footages
for ourselves inshallah.
So what you guys just saw this
in the skies thousands if not millions
of crows in Tel Aviv.
Why? Number two you saw on the ground in
traffic lights thousands of
thousands of crows literally.
And no one can say this a coincidence.
This is preordained. What does it mean?
So we know in mythology some people say
you know crows are a bad sign about
death and this and it's you know they
are
stuff of the god the gods or whatever
they want to call
so we're going to go to the email
inshallah brothers and sisters cuz what
this can also mean is that we don't we
know that crows do not usually eat human
flesh but they are known to eat the
flesh like meaning if a living human
being they're not going to come and bite
your flesh. But they are known that they
can eat dead human beings which means
this can point to massive massacre
should say massive amounts of people who
have been killed by the Iranian strikes
and the crows are there to eat their
bodies which shows that Israel is hiding
something that's happening. So
either that or other way around we're
going to talk about the signs of nine
signs Allah sent to Firaun.
Do you think that
you Zionists are going to get away with
the massacre of those blood? Do you
think Allah is going to allow you to
sleep peacefully at night knowing you've
killed 100,000 plus innocent cousins
committed a genocide? There's going to
be a cost to it. There's going to be a
cost to it. Let's read the Daily Mail
first. So here is what Daily Mail said
thousands of crows swarmed Tel Aviv
skyline sparking harbinger of doom
warning Iran's conflict. The skies over
Tel Aviv were flooded with sea of crow
crows on Tuesday in what many people are
saying is a harbinger of doom warning.
Thousands of crows were filmed circling
high-rise buildings including the iconic
Azrieli Tower in dramatic footage that
quickly went viral online. Many viewers
linked the eerie scene to Israel's
ongoing tensions with Iran claiming the
spectacle
sign signaled a looming disaster or what
they committed in Gaza. Okay Allah's
going to you think Allah's going to let
them get away with this?
Keep dreaming. This is considered by
many to be a harbinger of doom as if it
is often followed by total catastrophe.
On news on X said while others link it
to a biblical prophecy. The they cited
the book of Revelation 19 17 which
describes an an angel standing in the
sun shouting to birds flying in midair
to gather for the greatest
for the greatest supper of God. The
swirling flock created dark shifting
clouds over the skyline leaving
residents and viewers stunned by the
sheer scale of the migration. However
scientists who study birds said the
phenomena is not supernatural but part
of a routine seasonal migration along
one of the world's busiest bird flyways.
So how could it why would it be
supernatural? We didn't say they are
angelic birds you know why could it be
from God
as if that's going to explain it.
Experts noted that roughly 500 million
birds pass through Israel each year
during spring migration with hooded
crows frequently gathering in urban
areas during the nesting season. Okay so
again to me that can be that but again
this does not seem like a good sign. Now
what we can do is inshallah I want to
play a video from you guys where Allah
sends signs and Allah uses animals. We
do not know Allah says you do not know
the armies of Allah
and they can come from microorganisms to
birds. Yes okay so whatever it's about
that matter. Here is a video of nine
signs Allah sent Firaun where before he
totally destroyed them and that's going
to happen. Do you really think that any
religion for that matter that's a god
that you believe in that is a just god
is going to allow you guys to commit a
genocide and kill innocent people and
it's just going to be like yeah God's on
your side. Do you really believe God's
going to be on the side of a genocidal
maniacs?
Which who would worship a god that
allows the chosen people to massacre a
group of innocent people? Do you really
think you're on God's side? You're on
Satan's side. You guys are satanic
Zionists. Let's watch this video that
will educate you guys of the nine signs
that were sent to Firaun. 14 centuries
ago the Quran revealed the extraordinary
story of Hazrat Musa peace be upon him
known as Prophet Moses in other
traditions. Allah Subhanahu Wa Ta'ala
blessed him with nine clear miracles to
prove his prophethood and challenge the
arrogance of Pharaoh. Musa's simple
wooden staff became a living serpent
before Pharaoh and his magicians. When
Musa placed his hand under his arm and
withdrew it it shone with a radiant
light brighter than the sun yet without
harm.
This wasn't a burn or illusion. It was a
divine sign that stunned those who
witnessed it. Egypt's fertile land dried
under a severe drought. Imagine the
mighty Nile failing to nourish the
fields. Farmers watching crops wither a
clear message to Pharaoh that his power
could not command the skies. Then came
relentless floods. Imagine water rushing
through streets destroying homes and
harvests. The same Pharaoh who claimed
to be a god was now powerless before the
true creator.
Swarms of locust darken the sky and
devoured every green leaf.
To this day locust infestations can
destroy billions of dollars worth of
crops.
This was no ordinary plague but a
targeted strike against Pharaoh's pride.
Lice infested people and animals making
life unbearable.
Imagine waking up to frogs in your bed
your food your water.
Even Pharaoh's throne room wasn't
spared. Daily life became impossible
until Pharaoh begged Musa to pray for
relief.
The Nile the lifeline of Egypt turned to
blood. Fish died drinking water became
foul and panic spread.
Pharaoh's magicians could not reverse
the sign. It was Allah's command.
Finally a scarcity of fruit struck the
land. So there you go you can see that.
And not only that people made some
comments as well which I will read for
you guys inshallah. Somebody made a
comment saying the following.
By the way this is the this is the worst
possible omen at a civilization level
it's it's still taken seriously back
home in England and the Romans would
stop entire wars over the sign. It was
interpreted as this the gods have
withdrawn their protection over this
land. Now this is mysticism yes we don't
believe that but like I said before
this could be a sign. This could be a
sign God's wrath is going to rain on
Israel. And with what they have done
this is not far-fetched. So I just
wanted to bring that to your attention
guys inshallah and know that Allah
Ta'ala
is never ever going to let these vile
genocidal maniacs get away with what
they did to the Gazans. It's not going
to happen. There's going to be a price
to it and they can be arrogant and think
they're God's chosen people and they can
do whatever they like.
They're going to find out
the hard way. Okay so brothers and
sisters I thought I'd bring that to your
attention and as I get more news on this
matter
I will let you guys know. Till next time
As-salamu alaykum Wa Rahmatullahi Wa
Barakatuh. Everything you own from your
clothes to your car to your wife or your
husband is going to forget you and move
on and be replaced the moment you die.
That's what Allah says
you are busy with the worldly affairs
until you visit the grace. Brothers and
sisters Masjid Norway the one that we
built is looking to another Masjid
around the area of Norway where there's
so many Muslims that do not have
somewhere to pray. This masjid is only
$500,000. and And any donation that you
give will go towards your akhira.
Because when you enter that grave,
nobody's going to remember you except
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala. So, make it
count, brothers and sisters, and donate
towards this masjid, inshallah. A new
project that's only $500,000. And
believe me, if every single one of us
give £1, £10, £100, £1,000, that's going
to be something you will never regret on
Yawm al-Qiyamah. And everything that you
lose is going to perish and go. But your
deeds on Yawm al-Qiyamah are not.
Donate to the link, inshallah. Let's get
to the video.